what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are at the final story of
iron man before we get into superior
Iron Man but it's kind of funny here
because a lot of people who talk about
or know Stark the brother of Iron Man
this is the story where it just ends and
we never find out what happens with him
it's one of the biggest irritations that
Ironman fans have a lot of this is
because of the fact as superior Iron Man
was just like a holdover story until
only all-different marvel kicked off
when we had Avengers New Avengers Secret
Wars all that kind of stuff but the idea
with this is that in the last video we
had basically dealt with the rings of
the Mandarin now for the most part where
this continues that story the rings of
the Mandarin had always been this
interesting scenario I mean I would go
as far as to say that in a lot of ways
the reach of the Mandarin were based off
the Green Lantern mythos that is to say
Hal Jordan having a Green Lantern ring
the Green Lantern ring can make
constructs the reason why I say it's
largely based off that is because of
Marvel really in DC if I'm gonna be
honest for the most part when people
think of like superheroes that wear
rings they associate that with the Green
Lantern Hal Jordan with the Green
Lantern mythos the general idea here is
that the rings of the Mandarin made
their debut actually all the way back in
1961 I think it was and strange tales
number 89 and that actually dealt just
with the idea of the the mic luhan's I
think is how you pronounce their name I
can't remember but the idea is with the
Rings of the Mandarin serve different
purposes each ring can function
accordingly and what this story actually
does is it flushes out the nature of the
fact of the rings have some measure of
sentience initially we open up with
Malekith via cursed now what we don't
know is how this ring managed to get to
to the realm of the Dark Elves but the
fact that the range captured by Malekith
is a pretty big deal now remember these
are not like the Green Lantern rings
strictly a and DC Comics right like in
DC a Green Lantern ring will pop up to
you and it'll say you whoever's watching
this video you have been selected for
the Green Lantern Corps something along
those lines but then if it turns around
decides you're not worthy it'll just
leave you and go find somebody else with
this it's not the same way the Rings
seek people out but people can just
capture them they can just take them and
use the Rings for their own purposes now
keep in mind somebody to take note of
here and what we had talked about in the
last video with the character of Abigail
burns and a lot of these other members
who have been chosen for these various
rings of the Man
and they had basically received their
rings and the rings were acting in
accordance of people who had a grudge
with Tony Stark
whatever that grudge may be maybe they
just didn't like him as a person in this
instance is actually they had a Broadway
playing and they fired the director
because he was one of those weird
hipster art guys and the result was they
were like hey look nobody wants your
interpretation they just want to cool a
cool show and so they ended up caning
the guy the result was that he was just
pissed and he was given one of the rings
of the Mandarin picked it up and just
started using it against Iron Man so
again it's not really a very strict
process the overall gist with this is
that with Malick if basically taking one
of the Mandarin rings the goal is to use
all the Rings for himself now what this
does is this picks back up with Arno
stark and I remember at this point Arno
stark is very much a background
character if you're new to the whole
thing of Iron Man so far in our
different videos Arno Stark was
basically revealed to have been the
brother of Tony Stark that we never knew
about basically Arno is biologically
engineered he exists for the purpose of
basically being super smart he was
basically kept away this combined with
the fact that he was basically given a
short life span meant that he was
confined to a bed he really couldn't
move or anything this was because of the
fact that a Howard Stark had messed
around with the jeans and added a few
modifications and the result was that
Arno did not come out the way that he
was supposed to but the general gist of
this and the general idea is that this
focus is largely on the efforts of Tony
Stark to basically travel to fartole
home travel to the realm of the Dark
Elves basically capture Malekith and
take the Mandarin rings back because
that's what Malekith has been doing at
this moment there are four Mandarin
rings that are out there that we know
about and what we know is that Malekith
has been running around earth killing
those individuals who have those
Mandarin rings and then taking them now
of course this also ends up bringing in
a girl by the name of Siobhan and
Siobhan is like a weird situation when
it comes to Marvel it's like her dad
sold her soul to the devil that her dad
turned out to be evil it's this weird
thing but it goes all the way back to
like 1992 and I cannot remember the name
of her story for the life of me but she
is very obscure in a lot of different
ways but she's one of these characters
that exists out there in Marvel Comics
where she's really knowledgeable about
being able to blend technology with
magic and the reason this matters is
because of the fact that for Tony Stark
while he could basically go tell for say
hey look man Malekith of the dark house
is basically running around
grabbing these Mandarin rings and he's
gonna become super-powerful and then
probably invade Asgard Tori Stark and
Thor are not on the best of terms
remember this all follow this Hall comes
out to the events of siege and so for
the most part Asgard was destroyed in
siege now Tony Stark helped to rebuild
it but the idea is that Thor for the
most part still really just doesn't like
Iron Man following the events of civil
war where Thor learned that iron man had
basically cloned Thor and created this
cybernetic or the cyborg version of him
so again they're kind of on weird terms
now in truth for Tony Stark's worth in
this scenario the argument that he makes
is that this could very well lead to a
massive Asgardian think because there's
the Council of realms and all that kind
of good stuff and if he shows up on
Thor's doorstep and says hey look Malick
hit this capturing Mandarin rings well
then it turns into this big political
thing it turns into this Council of
realms coming together and then it's
like okay you who represent the Dark
Elves what do you have to say about this
and then it's well we don't have you
know we don't really know what you're
talking about we haven't really done
anything
Dennis debating and then it's deciding
if they're gonna do anything it's all
that bureaucracy all that talk well I
deal with that why not just go directly
to the heart of the problem the issue
with this is that this mission was
supposed to be a stealth mission and so
because of this when Tony Stark lands in
the realm of the Dark Elves he lands in
the middle of everything
he literally lands in the throne room of
malakut this is a terrible situation
form because under normal circumstances
if he was preparing to do this if it was
in the his intention to directly go
against Malekith he would have worn
armor that would allow him to do that
but in this instance this is black ops
armor this is armor that allows him to
basically camouflage this is armor that
doesn't make sounds and so because of
this you know showing up in the middle
of a throne room with armor that's
designed for secrecy as opposed to
combat does him almost no good now keep
in mind one of the discussions that we
had or one of the common threads that
went through our discussions when we ran
over all the different armors of Iron
Man is that all the armors were built
for combat on some level just because of
the fact that Tony Stark never knows if
he's gonna be on a recon mission and
he's gonna have to you know engage in
some measure of combat but there are
armors that are better suited for combat
than others and so again that's the
basis behind this this armor is not best
suited for combat at the same time
teleporting Tony Stark to Sparta Han is
huge because there's really only three
opportunities the power
the power basis used to do this is
massive and so what can only be done
three times meaning that if he sends
something to you know back to earth or
if something is sent to him and it uses
three charges there's no way for him to
get back and so the result of this is
that he really has no choice but to
fight Malekith or at least you know fend
off as best he can and then eventually
bail out now of course the reason for
this is because of the fact that Siobhan
had basically been working on a weapon
of sorts on some kind of technology that
would allow him to basically stun these
range to temporarily incapacitate the
person that's wielding them and then
take the rings away but something else
to point out here and this is where we
get into the whole sentience of it the
Rings basically speak with one another
and historically speaking I do not
believe this was an element of Mandarin
originally but with the Rings
communicating with one another what
we're basically getting here is this
idea that the Rings all basically Harbor
a grudge for Tony Stark now why they
hate him again we'll get into that as we
get through this but one thing that ends
up happening is that the various forces
of Malekith really kind of descend
directly on Tony Stark and so of course
again kind of fleeing running for his
life doing the best that he can facing
off against these forces here and
they're using guerrilla warfare tactics
he's able to hold his own to a degree
but in the end he ends up calling on
Siobhan to basically teleport an item
for the third time directly to him so of
course this basically uses up all the
charges and does not give him the
ability to necessarily teleport out and
so what ends up happening here is we
basically have Iron Man donning this
armor now of course I don't know if this
armor was directly specified in terms of
diversion that exists but is basically
anti Asgardian armor that's really what
it's designed for
this is armor that's designed to face
off against all forms of magic and
sorcery especially anybody who hails
from any of the other nine realms and
the reason why this matters is because
given the nature of this armor is
directly dangerous to the Dark Elves
themselves now the reason why I say that
is not necessarily because of like the
repulsor blasts of the of the suit or
anything on those lines but because Dark
Elves have an inherent weakness to iron
and so because the fact that they're
weak to iron this combined with a suit
basically being designed for combat
means that Iron Man is easily able to
overpower and incapacitate every last
one of them just by dispersing these
iron particles out into the air covering
them an iron dust
two different things like that so again
this is really cool because it really
kind of hits home into the idea of where
Ironman stands one thing to keep in mind
when it comes to the character of
Ironman this is something that people
tend to forget is the general public the
average person when the Ironman movie
was announced one of the biggest issues
that Marvel had when they made the film
was convincing people that Iron Man was
not a robot that it was actually a
person a lot of folks didn't really know
about him he was a pretty obscure
character in terms of the general public
the non comic reader and so when you
talk when you start talking about where
Ironman stands in relation to various
superheroes most people say he's a guy
in a suit of armor and at best he could
go against Captain America maybe Thor
depending on the circumstances what this
tells us is that what is with his
ingenuity his intelligence Tony Stark
can stand toe-to-toe against some pretty
big guys he's not like a lactis level
right like you're never gonna read a
story where Tony Stark is like yes I
have an armor that can withstand go like
this and if there is a story out there
that story's getting covered but as far
as I'm aware that story doesn't exist
the general sense here is that just kind
of using the weakness of the of the Dark
Elves to iron to his own advantage he's
able to systematically begin taking each
and every one of them out which
ultimately leads to him basically
capturing Malekith and then stripping
the ring away from Malekith now of
course this leads to Malekith basically
teleporting away the idea that one of
his servants just kind of shows up with
another ring that she had essentially
captured for herself Malekith ends up
grabbing this ring with the intention of
using it but this is the disintegration
ring this is the spectral range now this
is actually one of those rings that has
an interesting caveat for the most part
the rings can be used kind of endlessly
when it comes to the spectral ring
because of the fact that is designed to
basically break down matter on the
molecular level
if Marvel will turn around to say this
ring can be used at any time then you
would literally have a person just
running around dissolving everything in
existence and so what they did is they
created a caveat to say the ring can be
used but it has to be charged or it has
to charge itself for 20 minutes after
each use what ends up happening is that
this ring had already been used by the
servitor Malekith when she tried to
attack Tony Stark and so the result is
that when the ring initially pops up or
when Malekith puts it on he's got 20
minutes left until he can use it again
this also coincides with what appears to
be the arrival of the of the Asgardians
now of course this is not actually the
Asgardian
instead these are basically the six
other ring bearers of the Mandarin rings
the six rings that we haven't seen yet
but one of these rings is the lyre ring
this is the ring that serves the purpose
of tricking the eyes of individuals who
the ring is used on this instance is
used on Malekith tricking him into
believing all the Asgardians are there
now of course with these various members
who have all popped up again a lot of
these guys are enemies of iron man
himself but a lot of them are just
general bad guys but when it comes to
the arrival of these other Mandarin
rings this is basically what's been
happening where the Rings have been
communing with one another quote-unquote
where they've basically been talking to
each other their ultimate goal is to
defeat Tony Stark but with the other
four rings having been captured by
Malekith and being used by Malekith for
his own ends it basically disrupts the
plans of the other six rings and so the
goal was to essentially attach
themselves to six other individuals who
in turn would carry out the wishes of
the ring capture the other four from
Malekith and then allow the Rings to
function in unison and then achieve
whatever goal it was they wanted to
achieve and taking down Iron Man and so
the result here is that this basically
boils down to a circumstance where the
enemy of my enemy is my friend with Iron
Man having these rings he can't
necessarily put them on his fingers
because in truth I mean he can't really
use them through the suit and so the
result is that he kind of has to rely on
Malekith in order to basically help him
out now this is when we start invoking
the things of like magical promises and
so on and so forth in Marvel Comics one
of the most notable villains that
basically uses trickery and deception
when it comes to magical promises is
Mephisto and what Mephisto will do is
you'll pop up and he'll say okay I'm
gonna grant your greatest wish and
you'll say okay I wish I had a million
dollars and the Pfister will say okay
he'll give you a million bucks but you
won't live long enough to use any of it
that's the whole caveat that comes with
this character with Malekith it's much
the same way he'll grant your wish but
there's gonna be a trick there's gonna
be some kind of deception to it and so
of course with this and mine and with
Siobhan operating on earth basically
helping out Tony Stark throughout this
whole escapade
what she does is use her knowledge of
magic and technology to essentially
create this sort of binding contract
which is to say when Malekith says I
agree to help you out to help you get
out of this alive
there's no trickery to it there's no
backdoor deal there's no fine print and
so Malekith is basically bound to this
he couldn't violate it even if he wanted
to and so because of that he
essentially whisks Tony Stark away you
know when when he gives 20 start the
ring and they essentially teleport out
and so the landscape is now left open
for these other six mandarins to begin
achieving their own goals now of course
what it does is it basically brings all
the Rings back together again and so
with these rings basically being brought
back the idea is a now Tony Stark and
Arno working together look to basically
recapture these rings and then use them
for their own ends and that's what ends
up happening here is that with these
other mandarins that are out there their
goal is again to basically take down
Tony Stark and so because of this
working together Tony Stark and Arno
effectively invade their base of
operations now this is done in several
different ways you have Arno and you
have Tony who are piloting their own
suits of course onerous suit is
specifically designed to cater to the
fact that Arno doesn't have the ability
to walk or really move around at all but
then you also have things like the
Trojan army for example this massive
army of Iron Man suits that were
specially designed for the city of Troy
that city that we talked about in the
last few stories of course you also end
up having you know Abigail Burns who
basically shows up again it's one of
these really cool moments because you
sort of see this this giant Kingdom of
these mandarins just come crashing down
around them and so ultimately what we
end up finding out is that the person
who was in possession of the liar ring
is actually a guy named Mark now mark
was a character who was introduced in
invincible Iron Man annual number one I
think it was in 2010 and that came from
Matt Fraction and the whole idea with
Mark was that he was initially
introduced as a guy who was essentially
gonna be like a stand-in for happy hogan
to a degree one thing to keep in mind is
that happy hogan died in war for comics
like he's been dead for a while I'm
pretty sure the goal was to basically
begin the process of moving Pepper Potts
give her an actual future and so in that
story mark had basically proposed to her
after the two of them had spent time
together and of course she accepted the
issue with this was at marks perspective
of Tony Stark was a Tony Stark was a guy
who was really just kind of a dick and
so because of the fact of this built up
the idea that Tony Stark was so crass
that Tony Stark was so cruel to Pepper
ah what ended up happening is the liar
ring chose him to be able to wield it
and so that's the guy who's been running
around using this ring the entire time
this Lisa Tony Stark defeating mark and
and that's really all it is but what
this does is it basically begins the
process of answering the question of why
it is these rings hated Tony Stark so
much and this gets into the nature of
the resilience the
aliens basically started sending out all
these recorders of course we talked
about this during the secret origin of
Tony Stark but they started sending out
all these different you know recorders
for the purpose of mapping the universe
and observing everything and then
bringing that information back in this
instance because of the fact that the
Rings are basically technological the
explanation essentially goes like this
back when the rings were originally
created and the Mandarin just kind of
stumbled into them accidentally
discovered the range and then started
using them for his own ends the Rings
basically began to receive an imprint of
the Mandarin they basically kind of
began to instill his personality onto
the rings himself it was the idea that
the Rings began to absorb the idea that
Tony Stark was just a bad guy they just
wanted to take him out this combined
with the actions of the recorder 4-5-1
from the secret origin of Tony Stark
this same recorder had basically sort of
leaked its personality into the Rings
themselves as well as of the result is
that the Rings basically just kind of
became sentient and the goal was to just
take out Iron Man this were all that
comes from AI so the result is that once
everything begins to sort of get figured
out it all really just kind of begins to
wind down and that's really about it of
course the Rings are basically left in
the possession of Tony Stark himself for
him and are know to do what it is that
they want to do with it to basically use
them for their own purposes the problem
with this is that again this is the last
time we see our no we have not seen him
since it's basically just Iron Man and
Arno going off to do great things and we
never find out what happened to our no
we never see or hear from him again
and that's the biggest issue is because
when all-new all-different marvel picked
up an invincible Iron Man started we
never found out what happened to our
know we don't know if he's back in his
hospital bed we don't know if he's still
hanging out he's never been seen or
heard from he's literally a nonentity
and all-new all-different marvel now of
course Brian Michael Bendis has said
he's gonna go back and revisit the whole
issue with our know the whole concept of
where's character is and what he's been
doing which is cool and I'm really
excited about that but you know for
right now this just jumps directly into
Marvel's Oxus event and then goes into
superior Iron Man so that being said
guys we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here too
comments explained and make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]